[Musique]
je suis neuroscientifique et je viens
vous parler d'un nouveau scanner qu'on a
développé au sein de ma discipline qui
permet de regarder un cerveau humain ou
un groupe de personnes et de déterminer
en quelques millisecondes leur niveau
d'intelligence ça veut dire que là si je
le fais sur cette audience je pourrais à
la fin vous dire le classement du plus
intelligent intelligentes
au moins intelligente
bon c'est pas vrai je suis
neuroscientifique mais je viens plutôt
vous parler de pourquoi il ne faut pas
aller dans ce sens
et aussi de pourquoi on n'est pas si
loin que ça
alors cette question nous intéresse dans
ma discipline que ça soit les
neurosciences ou les sciences génétiques
c'est des questions qu'on se pose mais
c'est aussi des questions que vous vous
posez et peut-être nous avons tendance à
croire que un niveau élevé
d'intelligence tient d'une petite
poignée d'humain d'un don rare alors il
nous paraît évident par exemple dans nos
parcours scolaires intimes
professionnelles que nous sommes
différents au niveau de nos réalisations
et que certains se distinguent par une
facilité apparente pour les réaliser
donc il est incontestable que certains
réussissent mieux que d'autres et que
cette réussite leur prophète des
privilèges que d'autres n'ont pas devant
ces évidences on trouve dans le
concept d'intelligence innée une sorte
de refuge causal qui nous permet
d'expliquer d'où émerge une faculté
pourquoi elle nous fascine et surtout
pourquoi on la possède pas
tout au long de l'histoire scientifique
de l'intelligence les chercheurs se sont
interrogés sur comment est-ce qu'on peut
identifier comment est-ce qu'on peut
évaluer l'intelligence humaine avec des
méthodes plus ou moins visibles
au 19e siècle par exemple il se
passionnait pour le lien entre la taille
du cerveau et l'intelligence sans
pouvoir accéder directement au cerveau
ils utilisaient la taille de la tête
pour évaluer l'intelligence
Gustave Le Bon qui est un Parisien
intéressé par la psychologie
l'anthropologie il était un fervent
défenseur de cette recherche alors lui
lui il tenait particulièrement à
démontrer l'infériorité des races non
européennes mais quand même il avait la
même infection pour les femmes donc il
développe pas un céphalometre portable
qui l'amenant avec lui partout mesurer
la tête des gens et de toute évidence la
nature a accordé quelques onces
supplémentaires aux hommes blancs ce qui
explique leur supériorité intellectuelle
et justifie leur accès aux positions de
pouvoir et d'influence
les petits à petit on a commencé à se
rendre compte qu'il y a certains hommes
blancs éminents qui avaient des petites
têtes et donc c'était dit qu'il faut
qu'on se distancie de cette méthodologie
et plus tard elle a été réfutée cette
granuleologie mais d'autres méthodes qui
démontrent des différences biologiques
entre les groupes humains attendaient
quand même dans les coulisses une
différence de taille de cerveau une
bosse une anatomie et toutes ces
méthodes chercher obstinément à réduire
ce très complexe à un seul niveau et
toutes toutes ont été instrumentalisées
pour signifier que les hommes les blancs
les riches mériter leur position pouvoir
parce que naturellement biologiquement
il serait plus intelligent que les
femmes les pauvres et les minorités
raciales alors là vous pouvez peut-être
vous dire oui mais ça reflète la pensée
de l'époque ces vieux préjugés ont
balayés aujourd'hui mais en fait c'est
pas vrai parce que même aujourd'hui il y
a encore des explications déterministes
qui vont lier nos aptitudes
intellectuelles à un niveau génétique ou
à une partie de notre cerveau
à la fin du XXe siècle l'avènement des
nouvelles technologies d'imagerie ont
faire des cartes merveilleuses qui nous
font nous donne l'illusion d'une fenêtre
sur le cerveau
vous savez des images d'IRM
fonctionnelles qui continuent à
alimenter des fausses représentations
qui sont alimentées par la presse
populaire et qui continue à aggraver des
pensées pseudo scientifiques comme par
exemple que les femmes seraient plus
bavardes ou qu'elles sont incapables de
lire des cartes routières ou que les
hommes seraient biologiquement plus
doués pour les mathématiques la prise de
risque il y a des analyses génétiques
qui continuent sous couvert de
scientificité de signifier que les
enfants issus de famille riches ont un
QI naturellement supérieur ce qui
explique le réussite scolaire et social
donc justifiant par des explications
biologiques des hiérarchies sociales et
économiques
ironiquement à l'échelle universelle les
personnes qui ont un QI supérieur mais
issus de famille pauvres réussissent
moins que des personnes qui ont un QI
inférieur mais issus de famille riche ça
veut dire si vous êtes très favorisé
génétiquement mais pauvre vous avez
moins de chance de réussir que quelqu'un
de défavorisé génétiquement mes riches
d'autres types de privilèges semblent
l'importer sur notre biologie
les hommes blancs gagnent plus que les
hommes noirs plus éduqués et des hommes
garni plus que les femmes également
instruites donc les structures sociales
semblent déterminer beaucoup plus notre
biologie et elle détermine pas
simplement nos droits mais aussi la
manière avec laquelle on se perçoit
intellectuellement
ça veut dire si on se considère
intelligent ou pas ce qui a un impact
profond sur notre motivation sur notre
persévérance et sur nos aptitudes à
répondre aux tests d'aptitudes
intellectuelles
donc
qui à force de circonstances vous n'avez
pas accès à la bonne formation au bon
dispositif
aucun avantage génétique ne garantit que
vous allez réussir
ceci nous apprend quelque chose
d'essentiel sur la nature de
l'intelligence et son lien avec la
réussite nous avons beaucoup de chance
de la réaliser dans un contexte
privilégié
et beaucoup moins de chance de la
réaliser dans un contexte instable notre
capacité mentale ne dépend pas que de
nous et le droit de vigilance
scientifique face aux détournement de la
science et plus que jamais d'actuels
parce que même avec toutes les avancées
des neurosciences et des sciences
génétiques nous savons qu'un examen
détaillé des jeunes ou des zones de
cerveau ne rend pas compte de notre
complexité humaine alors ces méthodes
sont utiles prometteuses passionnante
mais si on se restreint à leur prisme ce
serait comme si on est dans un
embouteillage on veut comprendre
pourquoi on est dans un embouteillage on
veut le résoudre et on se met à ouvrir
les capots des voitures et analyser leur
moteur on serait pas au bon niveau
d'analyse et aussi sophistiqué qu'elles
puissent vous paraître et nous paraître
scientifique
ces critères actuels de test cognitif
de d'imagerie d'analyses génétique ne
rentre pas compte de notre complexité
nous pouvons quand même nous entendre
sur quelques faits de l'intelligence qui
peuvent nous aider à faire avancer le
débat d'abord l'intelligence
n'est pas un très monolithique comme les
descriptions classiques de notre taille
de la couleur de leurs yeux c'est un
trait complexe elle qui n'est pas
soigneusement emballer étiqueté ranger
sur un seul brin d'ADN même biner Alfred
Binet le monsieur qui a inventé le test
de QI en 1904 il savait que ce serait
impossible de réduire ce trait complexe
à un seul chiffre lui il a été missionné
par le ministère de l'Éducation pour
développer un test psychométrique qui
nous permet d'identifier les élèves qui
ont des difficultés d'apprentissage pour
les accompagner et pas pour les exclure
ça veut dire
que ce test a été conçu à une époque où
on ne voyait pas l'intelligence comme un
phénomène complexe et où on ne savait
pas d'ailleurs grâce aux neurosciences
que le cerveau est façonné et modelé par
toutes les expériences de la vie
ce qui m'amène à mon deuxième point
notre vision moderne et populaire des
tests et qu'il fournissent une mesure
fixe l'intelligence or l'intelligence
change au cours de la vie dans les
années 90 un chercheur néo-zélandais Jim
fine a découvert que chaque décennie
l'humanité gagnée en moyenne 3 points de
cul ça veut dire sur le 20e siècle aura
gagné à peu près 30 points ce qui est
énorme et personne ne peut prétendre que
nous avons évolué génétiquement en
quelques générations ce qui s'est
produit c'est que nous avons été exposés
à la logique abstraite que les tests de
QI mesure
et peut-être les études les plus
optimistes viennent de d'expérience qui
nous montre que une année supplémentaire
d'éducation peut augmenter le QI de 1 à
5 points ce qui montre que on a
peut-être rien trouvé encore de plus
robuste de plus cohérent
que l'éducation pour accroître notre
intelligence mais après il faut aussi
savoir de quelle intelligence on parle
dans notre société moderne
occidentale comment est-ce qu'on
explique l'intelligence par une rapidité
par une précision de nos facultés
cognitives mais comment on conçoit
l'intelligence c'est une affaire
culturelle et une affaire historique
dans beaucoup d'autres cultures une
adaptation réussie ne correspond pas à
un autre façon de comprendre
l'intelligence dans certaines cultures
africaines rurales les enfants qui
arrivent à collaborer qui arrivent à
aider les adultes dans des tâches
importantes sont considérées les plus
intelligents alors s'il réussissent à
l'école ils sont respectés mais s'ils
arrivent pas à être solidaires avec les
autres ce ne serait pas les plus
intelligents du groupe
donc réviser notre manière de regarder
l'intelligence ne signifie pas que c'est
un appel à rejeter toutes les tentatives
de comprendre les liens entre notre
biologie et nos aptitudes mais plutôt
c'est un appel
à créer des opportunités adaptées à
notre complexité qui écrase toutes nos
tentatives de diagnostic et de
classement
c'est un appel ça n'appelle qui est
urgent parce que il est lié à la façon
avec laquelle on se regarde on regarde
les autres et il a des implications
majeures sur les objectifs et les
décisions qui régissent un des champs
dans lesquels les fictions des aptitudes
naturelles sont les plus prégnantes qui
est l'école parce que les conséquences
sociales des tests de mesure
d'intelligence au sein de l'école
deviennent tellement discriminatoires
quand il viennent justifier et masquer
des inégalités en faveur du de ceux qui
sont considérés les plus doués parce que
l'école ne peut pas être juste un lieu
d'évaluation où on évalue l'accumulation
de connaissances et l'activation de
fonction cognitives elle peut être un
lieu rêvé dans lequel on remet nos
hypothèses du monde en question elle
peut être un espace
dans lequel on se permet le luxe
inconfortable de changer d'avis et de
nous entraîner à négocier et accepter
nos différences alors cela ne veut pas
dire qu'il faut en mettre en question la
génialité et l'originalité de certaines
prouesses que certains puissent briller
académiquement et certes possible mais
cela ne doit pas être vu comme une
validation de la nature biologique de
l'intelligence mais plutôt comme un
appel à regarder qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans leur parcours rendu possible cette
capacité ça veut dire que les questions
que nous pouvons nous poser
détourne notre attention depuis qu'est
ce qu'il a de magique dans ses gènes ou
qu'est-ce qu'elle a de magie dans ces
gènes à quelle formation adapter à telle
relie ou u de quel fait c'est pencher
sur son berceau à quelle formation
a-t-il ou a-t-elle suivi de quel courage
mystique leur permet de persévérer à
quel méthode motivante aurait été exposé
et cela ne nous interdit pas de nous
émerveiller de ce que la démarche
individuelle est singulière peut
produire et de ce que le processus de
pensée peut générer en essai en erreur
en rêverie en improvisation en
incertitude tout cela est une beauté
flagrante
et ne nous empêche absolument pas
d'observer les structures dans
lesquelles ces phénomènes ont lieu et
cela s'applique à toutes nos tentatives
de réduire au niveau individuel ou une
partie de notre individu comme une
partie de notre cerveau ou quelque chose
dans nos gènes quelque chose qui est
social culturel historique géographique
c'est un peu comme si on s'émerveille
d'une plume d'oiseaux
de ses propriétés de ces dimensions de
sa douceur de sa couleur mais tout en
gardant à l'esprit que cela ne nous dit
pas pourquoi voilà un oiseau dans quel
sens et à quelle hauteur merci
[Applaudissements]